[Music]  I don't regret staying at home and being  your mom but I regret not getting my  degree  that's why somebody's mom just enrolled  in college I'm referring to myself I'll  see you around the quad nobody says that  mom well bring it back I think those  dads just checked you out just looking  at my smock it tends to catch the light  mom you're a college girl now and we got  to make some changes  no we don't know where that's been oh  god what are you 20 a nurse Lex no shut  up fray I'm older and wiser this  essentially a Google ask me anything  turn off your Google you're scaring me I  think my the Google scared jack last  night oh my god but in a good way I like  when you intentionally go through a  haunted house  you